the man who co-founded the company that
makes Yankee Candles Oh stir toaster
ovens and bicycle playing cards is on
track to become one of the highest paid
executives in the United States jarden
gave Martin Franklin restricted chair's
worth about 74 million dollars putting
his total reported pay for 2014 at about
ninety six million dollars jarden
however recorded this stock award as
having no value bloomberg's laura
marcinek joins me now in studio Laura
how did we find this out we found this
out because we have an amazing executive
compensation team I have to credit under
smellin gens analyst Alicia ritzy for
finding this they they went beyond the
summary compensation table which is
where people typically look at executive
pay in a proxy statement and they stop
there they don't do exactly so they dug
and they found this this grant that
wasn't accounted for in the summary
compensation table which is pretty
uncommon oh yes million no doubt why did
the company account for this award this
way sure so there's a there's a
Financial Accounting Standards Board
guidance that says if the performance
conditions that are tied to that award
are improbable then they don't have to
value it so they can value it at zero so
Jarden said that these these revenue and
eps goals that they set were indeed
improbable allowing them to then value
it at zero okay it's don't need mean to
make light of it but sound four million
dollars does not seem improbable right
talk to us about Jordan tell sorry
jarden you know at first glance you you
don't really recognize it it's not one
of these big companies that's out in the
public too much but you don't know who
we are but you know what we make we you
know we make and it includes coleman
camping gear and bicycle playing cards
and i probably seen all you see that on
your screen you've probably seen all of
those logos at some point exactly so the
rawlings baseball gear it's all very
familiar brands and they have tons of
them so they're they're the type of
company that has has acquired these
brands over time and they turn them
around and and make them more profitable
what are their financials look like
right now so their financials right now
there they have about eight point three
billion in revenue last year and
earnings per share of 272 dollars and
seventy cents and they're targeting what
these improbable goals are it's ten
billion in revenue and four dollars
earnings per share so so that's kind of
the lay of the land and by the way they
need to make these goals by 2018 the
performance conditions yes are they
achievable well we have a bunch of
analysts that say they're achievable and
sir passable by the time 2018 rolls
around so that's why this is a little a
little odd you know they're setting
these goals they're saying they're
improbable and then we have analysts who
follow the company who say oh my gosh
they'll definitely achieve this no
problem in fact the Bloomberg estimate
for earnings is already at four dollars
and 14 cents for 2008 to as the company
done this before yes they have in 2010
they did the same type of thing they
gave him a big stock award that they
valued at zero saying the awards were or
the performance conditions were
improbable and then it fested in 2013
after they didn't achieve or did achieve
those performance goals that they set he
talked about members of your team who
did the digging for this story I'm
looking at our story here on the
Bloomberg terminal and you guys spoke to
ron Baton oh he's a vice president and
compensation consultant at ferry and
advisors and he said in an email and I
quote this grant approach appears to
allow a company to skirt the summary
compensation table disclosure and he
continued it does not strike me as the
best practice did we hear from Jordan we
did and they declined to comment
specifically on the perform excuse me
specifically on the treatment the
accounting treatment the accounting a
treatment of the award but they did
comment on the long-term aspirational
goals that they like to set for their
CEOs to or for their executives in
general to incentivize them and that's
not an uncommon practice of course it's
encouraged to type 80 performance
but the idea of saying something is
improbable and therefore valuing that
award at zero that's the more uncommon
practice that we're seeing no we began
this by talking about it's not one of
those things that you look for at first
blush when you look at this statement
you're really not looking for this was
there anything that key the team that
said you know what let's dig a little
deeper or was this just they found a
needle in a haystack uh I you know it's
if you look in the right places that's
there there are other tables that
disclosed this we have very smart people
who know exactly where to look for this
type of thing and they found it and I
have to give me credit for that